تاسس لواء جولاني قبل ثلاثه اشهر من اعلان
دوله اسرائيل عام
1948 ويعرف ايضا باللواء رقم واحد لانه من
اوائل الويه المشا في الجيش الاسرائيلي
سمي بهذا الاسم نسبه الى هضبه الجولان
السوريه المحتله لتمركز في منطقه الجليل
يضم اللواء اربع كتائب رئيسيه ويصنف جنوده
من قوات النقبه نظرا للتدريبات القاسيه
التي يتلقونها قبل احاق خدم في صفوفه
العديد من القاده السياسيين والعسكريين في
اسرائيل من ابرزهم رئيس الوزراء الاسبق
ارئيل شارون شارك في كل الحروب الكبرى
التي خاضتها اسرائيل منذ العام
48 كالعدو الثلاثي عام
1956 وحرب اكتوبر عام 73 واجتياح لبنان
عام
1982 وحرب تموز مع حزب الله في 2006 اضافه
الى الحرب الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه في
2014 التي تعرضت قواته فيها الى كمين كبير
للمقاومه في حي الشجاعيه اسفر عن مقتل 14
من جنوده واصابه قائد اللواء غسان عليان
في الحرب الحاليه تعرضت الكتيبه الثال عش
في اللواء الى كمين في حي الشجاعيه ايضا
اسفر عن مقتل عشره من جنودها من بينهم
قائدها تومر جرينبرج ليصل عدد قتلاها
الكلي في معارك غزه الى 42
وجنديا وكان لواء جولاني قد خسر 7 من
جنوده وضباطه في الهجوم الذي شنته كتائب
القسام في السابع من اكتوبر الماضي